sur france 24 éditions spéciales la
guerre aux portes de l'europe puisque
depuis le début de la matinée bien la
russie mènent des bombardements aériens
et des tirs d'artillerie en ukraine le
territoire ukrainien largement envahi
par les colonnes de blindés de l'armée
russe un héros en militaires aux abords
de kiev est tombée aux mains des russes
tout comme la centrale nucléaire de
tchernobyl j'accueille à présent à nos
côtés olivier schmitt professeur de
relations internationales directeur
d'études et de recherches à l'institut
des hautes études de défense nationale
bonjour jean yves le drian s'est exprimé
il ya quelques instants il le rappelle
l'otan est une alliance nucléaire at il
raison de le faire alors que joe biden a
lui même exclu eu un engagement
américain en ukraine il faut
effectivement distinguer la question de
l'engagement au profit de l'ukraine et
la question de la protection des
frontières de l'otan comme vous le savez
l'ukraine a des frontières directement
avec des états membres de l'otan pologne
roumanie et il est normal du point de
vue de l'alliance de signaler que une
toute incursion
délibérer dans un territoire de l'otan
est toujours couverte par le parapluie
nucléaire de l'otan et par l'article 5
donc en fait on fait du signalement
nucléaire c'est assez classique dans une
manoeuvre de dissuasion telle que celle
ci dut finalement nucléaire il ya quand
même un risque aujourd'hui pour les
états limitrophes et les états baltes
notamment qui auparavant et bien été
eux-mêmes
appartenait à l'union soviétique et qui
aujourd'hui sont des pays membres de
l'otan a absolument les états baltes
sont évidemment inquiet je pense à titre
personnel que actuellement de les forces
russes étant engagé en ukraine et le
dispositif militaire russe étant orienté
autour de l'invasion actuelle il n'y a
pas de risque immédiat pour les états
baltes mais bien évidemment il est dans
la logique de la dissuasion est dans la
logique politique de l'otan de rappeler
que le parapluie d'articles 5 est
toujours valide parce que les signaux
comme ça rentre dans cette interaction
stratégique où chacun essaie d'intimider
l'autre vladimir poutine a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises le
la puissance nucléaire que représente
aujourd'hui la russie pensez vous qu'il
soit prêt faire usage de cette arme est
concrètement jusqu'où d'après vous va
aller son offensive en ukraine alors le
signalement nucléaires tels que fait la
russie est assez constant en fait dans
leurs manoeuvres de coercition il y
avait eu la même chose en 2014 où il
avait expliqué attention je vous
rappelle que la russie est un état
nucléaire pourquoi vous avez le moindre
idée de soutenir les ukrainiens
régulièrement les russes font du
signalement nucléaire de cette manière
en termes d' intimidation donc ça fait
partie de cette voie là cette manoeuvre
d'intimidation
régulière qui rentre dans le cadre de la
doctrine nucléaire russe ensuite pour
revenir à votre question sur quel est
l'objectif je crois le plus que
l'objectif a été assez clairement
explicitées si on avait le moindre doute
dans le discours de lundi soir où il dit
explicitement que le cren le régime
ukrainien n'est pas légitime or aux yeux
de la russie et que il en il s'agit de
le des nazis fier ce qui est quand même
un mots extrêmement forts qui est
absurde étant des êtres la situation
politique ukrainienne mais qui est un
signal donné pour justifier
éventuellement des des mesures assez
fortes y compris de capture
d'emprisonnement des intellectuels de la
santé suivi six villes ukrainiennes et
je crois que étant donné la manoeuvre
elle-même et la pénétration des forces
russes en ukraine il s'agit probablement
d'un changement de régime par la force
c'est un état croupion de moscou ouvrait
ses portes à je pense que la russie a
compris que la société civile
ukrainienne et le l'ukraine en général
ne serait pas un allié pour les 30
prochaines années et qu'ils sont dans
une démarche de qu'ils me haïssent
pourvu qu ils le craignent et
cécile si vous n'êtes pas des alliés au
moins que ce soit pour une bonne raison
et donc il s'agit effectivement de
d'avoir au lieu d'avoir un état hostile
et qui réussit à ses portes à voir un
état affaibli et qu'on peut contrôler
d'une certaine manière parallèlement le
partenariat avec la biélorussie se
renforce considérablement il ya la
volonté chez vrai demir cottyn demain de
redéfinir les frontières russes
alors pour la biélorussie depuis une
trentaine d'années en fait depuis la fin
de la guerre froide la biélorussie avait
toujours réussi à négocier une forme
d'autonomie c'est à dire en étant
évidemment proche de la russie mais en
ayant une marge de manoeuvre
diplomatique en n'étant jamais
complètement en ligne et il est vrai que
les manifestations de l'an dernier ont
dé facto fortement affaibli le président
qui ne gêne pas loukachenko qui ne voit
sa survie politique désormais que au
prix d'un alignement très fort avec la
russie et la russie vit dans en profite
il va y avoir un référendum ce week end
sur la possibilité de déployer des armes
nucléaires en en biélorussie des armes
nucléaires russes en biélorussie ce qui
est un changement assez profond de la
manière dont les accords d'armement en
europe avait été organisée à la fin la
guerre froide créer ou recréer une
grande russie c'était le projet
d'origine de vladimir poutine ou bien il
se contente de saisir les opportunités
de l'offre l'époque je pense que du
point de vue de vladimir poutine ya
toujours eu une forme de revanchisme qui
est assez net dans sa trajectoire
politique étant donné qu'il est étant
donné la manière dont il a vécu la fin
de la guerre froide il était à dresde il
a raconté
plusieurs fois que ça il avait vécu
comme une humiliation personnelle le
fait de voir les citoyens allemands
tapez littéralement à la porte du kgb du
bureau du kgb de l'époque et lui essayé
d'avoir des ordres de moscou et que
moscou ne répondait pas et là il a vécu
comme une nation personnes dont il ya
toujours une part de revanchisme et je
pense qu'il ya effectivement une part
d'opportunités à travers à la fois un
appareil militaire russe qui a été
rebâti qui aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
faire performant que ce qu'il était par
exemple en 2008 ce lors de la de la
crise avec la géorgie et en même temps
ce qu'il estime être une configuration
politique où les états unis sont
affaiblis ou les européens sont
peut-être d'istres et et une fenêtre
d'opportunité en se disant que l'arménie
chrétienne sera meilleure en 2025 que ce
qu'elle est en 2022 et que quitte à
atteindre cet objectif autant
l'atteindre plutôt que plus tard ses
intentions les tempes oseo